hi and welcome to my video series of bio
techniques explained in five minutes
where I explain a concept in biology in
less than five minutes or so so if you
haven't yet subscribed to my channel hit
that subscribe button and please leave
some comment below after watching this
video that keeps me motivated to make
more such videos so today's installment
we'll be talking about genomic DNA
libraries so what comes in your mind
when we talk about a genomic DNA library
a library means a collection of books so
a genomic DNA library would simply mean
a collection of genomic DNA right okay
so these days it is high-throughput
sequencing era where we can in fraction
of seconds two minutes we can sequence a
full genome but let me take you too far
70s where sequencing was not so much
developed but people were eager to
sequence the genome of yeast bacteria
virus and even human but there was a
huge challenge in this work because the
genomic size a mammalian genome would be
in order of 10 to the power 9 base pairs
so big right now there are 3 basic
problems how to clone such a big genome
then where to clone it what are the
appropriate vectors which would be
useful for cloning such a huge quantity
and then even if we clone it
successfully then how we can like
identify our sequence of interest from
this library of the sequence so
screening of this library was another
challenge now scientists were always
bothered that ok if we try to approach
this problem we should first understand
what vector to use second we should
understand that even if the cloning is
successful we should devise a efficient
strategy and before that we should have
an estimate that how many recombinant
colonies we have to screen so these were
the challenges at that era now human
if we talk about the human genome which
is like some around 2.8 into 10 to the
power 6 kilo base pairs and we desired
to clone it
I wanted to appreciate that how
difficult it would be because let's say
we want to clone it and we would
restrict restriction digest this whole
genome and and let's for a moment assume
that we are going to clone it inside a
bacteriophage and the insert size the
insert of our fragment that we are going
to clone would be 20 KB in order to
cover this whole genome with such 20 KB
fragments we would at least need to
point 8 into 10 to the power 6 KB
divided by 20 which is aprox
to 10 to the per five fragments at least
this number of recombinants we have to
scream but imagine the number is more
than that because sometimes some
particular fragment would be
over-represented and some fragments
would be underrepresented so we have to
in order to be safe and get the whole
coverage we need to screen more colonies
now it's still difficult you can
understand how challenging it is
mathematically to imagine how many
colonies to screen now Clarke and carbon
came up with a formula the formula is
very looks very simple yet elegant so
they calculated number of individual
recombinants to be screened based on a
probability so they defined a
probability P which is including a DNA
fragment in a random library and they
came up with this formula now if we
consider we want to screen the human
genomic library with 95% probability and
provided our insert size was 20 kilo
base pair then plugging in all the
values to this formula gives us at least
we need for point 2 into 10 to the power
5 number of recombinant colonies to be
screened which was the number pretty big
that we got earlier so
was like 1.4 into 10 to the power 5 now
the number is 4 time more than the
minimum number right now if we want to
have a probability which is 99% which we
are becoming more stringent towards the
coverage we have to screen even more
colonies and screening 6 point 5 or 4
point to 10 to the power 5 colonies is
not a joke so it was damn challenging at
that time next question is what vector
should be appropriate to make a genomic
DNA library so there are two options one
option was lambda fudge lambda fudge
based vectors are easy to screen
thousands of lambda fast vector could be
screened simultaneously and their
transformation efficiency is pretty high
even higher than the bacteria in
comparison to that the carrying capacity
of bacterial artificial chromosome is
pretty high than these lambda phage
vectors so bigger fragments cloning
bigger fragments is easier in back so
both the approaches could be taken to
clone the genomic DNA library now in
lambda fudge vector so their genome is
49 kilo base pair and few interesting
facts about their genome is one third of
their genome is just trash they don't
need that so instead of that particular
genomic region it could be replaced with
our gene of interest or the DNA sequence
of interest so we can cut this stuff off
a fragment out and we can insert our DNA
of interest and we can have several
thousand plucks created by these lambda
phage vectors but now question comes
which restriction enzyme to use imagine
we use a for base cutter or a six base
cutter only one type of restriction
enzyme so only one type of restriction
fragment will be generated only one type
of length would be generated with no
overlap with the previous one
is that advantageous there are also
other options where we use to
restriction enzymes they say one for
base cutter and one six base cutter in
combination and we do a partial
digestion which would give rise to
several different random fragment
lengths but each of them has a
probability that it would overlap with
some other fragments so there could be
two strategies but which would be useful
imagine if you have a puzzle and you
know that puzzle gives rise to a picture
and you you get some amount of the
information of the previous block it's
easy for you to solve the puzzle now if
you don't have any overlap between the
other puzzle blocks it would be lot more
difficult to solve the puzzle right so
scientists always wanted to have more
overlap such that they had more clue and
they don't get lost when they are
screening the libraries so that's why
nowadays people use a combination of
restriction enzymes and do a partial
digest for cloning now after the cloning
when you get the recombinant colonies on
Petri plates you can take them out and
you can screen them sequence them and
you get multiple different sequences of
different lengths definitely right now
we you know that these sequences have
some degree of overlap with each other
that you can call continue and then
keeping one particular landmark and
arranging all the skal this context on
one top of another you can retrieve the
physical map of the genome and that is
how the scientists solved the this
genomic library problem and they really
sequence the genome like this so that is
how genomic DNA library was pretty
useful at that particular point of time
now there are other type of libraries
like cDNA libraries which I had a
different video of but serial libraries
are different genomic DNA library would
contain all the sequence including
introns exon non-coding repetitive
sequence everything but serial libraries
would only have the the the sequence of
exons which are expressed
now cDNA library would only have some
sequence of those genes which are
expressed at that point of time but
genomic DNA library would have the
sequence information for all the genes
which are present in that organism at
any given point of time so genomic DNA
libraries would in terms of sequence
would give a better idea than a cDNA
library but cDNA library is useful in
its own way I hope you enjoyed this
video if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up and please let me know
in my comments that how you are liking
these videos and don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you